and from what we learned today the nfl
is upset that some raiders were
apparently too cavalier in their efforts
to stop the spread of covet
sports director chris matthews joins us
more live in studio on what the league
found out and what are the consequences
chris
well thank you brian yeah one player
another group of players disregard for
the nfl protocols now is causing nfl to
move the raiders game
off the prime time sunday night slot on
sunday afternoon the game's going to be
played now
and that's still not set in stone could
be pushed to monday perhaps
lyman trent brown won't play regardless
he tested positive
and the nfl network reported he wasn't
wearing a mandated tracker
the other linemen sent home yesterday
were seen on video not wearing masks
and were in contact with brown on monday
so technically
they could be cleared to play on sunday
if the tests continue to read negative
same with jonathan abram nfl network
reporting today that no new positives
from wednesday's testing
as for now those who are cleared they
will play they're
they're going to play regardless of the
time or day they're excited to go out
there and play
at the end of the day we all knew that
it was going to be some some
some ups and some downs and you had to
deal with a bit of bs you know i mean
while you're going into the season but
you know as far as just the game this
pattern you know we can we can line up
and play tomorrow it don't really matter
to us you know what i mean
in the day we love our guys we trust in
the guys we got here regardless of
whether
you know those five guys play or not
you know don't really matter to us you
know so we're gonna be ready
games have also been moved and pushed
around and rescheduled so the raiders
aren't alone it's just kind of a shame
though because
it was the big sunday night prime time
game so the raiders and buccaneers play
at one o'clock instead of 5 p.m on
sunday vegas
still has two more prime time games
scheduled they host the chiefs on sunday
night in november
they'll also play the chargers on
thursday night at allegiant stadium
in december brian